so I have two different random variables
here and what I want to do is think
about what type of random variables they
are so this first random variable X it's
equal to the number of sixes after
twelve roles of a fair die well this
looks pretty much like a binomial random
variable in fact I'm pretty confident it
is a binomial random variable we could
just go down the checklist the outcome
of each trial can be a success or
failure so trial outcome success or
failure it's either gonna go either way
the result of each trial is independent
from the other ones whether I get a six
on the third trial is independent on
whether I got a six on the first or the
second trial so result let me write this
trial I'll just do a shorthand trial
results results independent independent
that's an important condition let's see
there are a fixed number of trials fixed
number of trials in this case we're
going to have twelve trials and then the
last one is we have the same probability
on each trial same probability of
success probability on each trial so yes
indeed this met all the conditions for
being a binomial binomial random random
variable and this was all just a little
bit of review about things that we have
talked about in other videos but what
about this thing in the salmon color the
random variable Y so this says the
number of rolls until we get a six on a
fair die so this one strikes us is a
little bit different but let's see where
it is actually different
so doesn't meet that the trial outcomes
that there's a clear success or failure
for each trial well yeah we're just
gonna keep rolling so each time we roll
it's a try
and success is when we get a six
failures when we don't get a six so the
outcome of each trial can be classified
as either a success or failure so it
meets and Lumi up with the checks right
over here it meets this first constraint
our the results of each trial
independent well whether I get a six on
the first roll or the second roll or the
third roll or the first fourth roll or
the third roll it the probabilities
shouldn't be dependent on whether I did
or didn't get a six on a previous roll
so we have the independence and we also
have the same probability of success on
each trial in every case it's a 1/6
probability that I get a 6 so this stays
constant and I skipped this third
condition for a reason because we
clearly don't have a fixed number of
trials over here we could just we could
roll 50 times until we get a 6 the
probability that we'd have to roll 50
times is very low but we might have to
roll 500 times in order to get a 6 in
fact think about what the minimum value
of Y is and what the maximum value of Y
is so the minimum value that this random
variable can take I'll just call it min
Y is equal to what well it's gonna take
at least one roll so that's the minimum
value but what is the maximum value for
Y and I'll let you think about that all
assumed you thought about it if you
pause the video well there is no Max
value you can't say oh it's a billion
because there's some probability that it
might take a billion in one rolls it is
a very very very very very very small
probability but there's some probability
it could take a googol roles or
Googleplex rolls so you can imagine
where this is going so this type of
random variable where it meets a lot of
the constraints of a binomial random
variable each trial has a clear success
or failure outcome the probability of
success on each trial is constant the
trials the trial results are independent
of each other but we don't have a fixed
number of trials in fact it's a
situation we're saying how many trials
do we need to get do we need to have
until we get success maybe that's a
general way of framing this type of
random very
how many trials until success while the
binomial random variable was how many
trials or how many successes I should
say how many successes in finite number
of trials so if you see this general
form and it meets these conditions you
can feel good it's a binomial random
variable but if you're meeting this
condition clear success or failure
outcome independent trials constant
probability but we're not talking about
the successes in a finite number of
trials we're talking about how many
trials until success then this type of
random variable is called a geometric
geometric random random variable and we
will see why in future videos it is
called geometric because the math that
involves the probabilities of various
outcomes looks a lot like geometric
growth or geometric sequences and series
that we look at in other types of
mathematics and in case I forgot to
mention the reason why we call binomial
random variables is because when you
think about the probabilities of
different outcomes you have these things
called binomial coefficients based on
combinatorics and those come out of
things like Pascal's triangle and when
you take a binomial to ever-increasing
powers so that's where those words come
from but in the next few videos the
important thing is to recognize the
difference between the two and then
we're gonna start thinking about how do
we deal with geometric random variables